a claustrophobic space horror about an
alien that kills people probably a good
mood for this movie to come out before
alien covenant so life is a space horror
with three a-list actors Jake Gyllenhaal
Ryan Reynolds and Reynolds brings his
flavor but Jake Gyllenhaal's more or
less than Maine well and during the
International Space Station which is
actually a space station that's actually
up there in orbit they get these Mars
soil samples I find out hey there's some
bacteria in there and they work to
really assess it ate it cellular CPR so
to speak then this thing comes alive it
gets really smart grosser than
exponential right then yeah you have a
thing that kills people and eats them
space harm and the train was leading up
to this movie I was like this movie
could suck or it could be great I
considered this like the dark horrors of
2007 things really rooting for this one
there are things to like in life really
right off the bat I was fascinated it
really makes you think like what would
we do if we found something like that we
would try to bring it to life and then
what life is brutal it's messy and
organisms survive by consuming other
organisms see they're not going to work
out well for it or not going to work out
well for us robably adds Agron one I
know on the trailers show that one
scientist putting his hand in there like
poking the thing and the trailer looks
dumb as I was watching the movie I look
I'd probably have my hand in there too
like that's so awesome I'd be the first
to go what can I say but you really do
understand why the thing didn't seem too
hostile didn't show a lot of intelligent
they didn't just put his hand in there
it's one of those things where you have
the gloves and it's made for tinkering
with [ __ ] and dad just goes awry it's
really fascinating how it goes a ride
really you look at the movie in a very
biological and reactionary standpoint
what I mean by that is the humans do
something and then the thing reacts but
if the humans had not done what they did
would the thing be trying to kill them
up probably since it still needs that
you know eat and that the first half is
really good super claustrophobic you
don't know where the thing is small in
the second half of the movie happens
where the thing grows up gets bigger and
now he's just picking them up and it
doesn't have as much mystery to it yeah
we say the first half of the movie is
definitely better than the second half
of the minute when the movie is doing
it's claustrophobic horror well it
really does work the hallways are narrow
the hiding spaces are narrow couple
times people are in peril this thing is
just getting
better of them and it's doing it to
survive for a while you do get it or
like the thing is just it's killing
people because it needs to survive then
yeah the second half of the movie hits
and the thing just becomes a really evil
[ __ ] and you're like oh it's just a
dick but the scientists in is just
killing people to survive and kind of
ambiguous not it's a dick guys in the
end the first half of life looks like
life was going to be what I wanted life
to be a fascinating science are on the
fringe of reality it makes you ask the
questions of what is an apex predator
are we it is this how it started and is
this thing really a dick or is it just
trying to survive all the while doing
some very effective claustrophobic are
in the second half of this movie happens
those questions are no longer on the
table there's a lot of cliche
claustrophobic science fiction horror I
did enjoy life the actors did a good job
and in the end it is a good time no
alcohol required there was a rumor going
around this movie may be like a venom
prequel like the Venom symbiote from a
Spider Man you know that Sony wants to
do a venom movie then this movie's
coming out and from the trailer it kind
of looks like it has qualities of the
Venom symbiote but it's not it's not
that at all I tell you that so you go
into this movie not hoping for that and
disappointed with it doesn't happen I
guys so like have you seen it what did
you think about it or what's your
favorite sci-fi horror or biological
horror or maybe a guilty pleasure one
because a lot of you are going to say
alien but whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]